there is a long tradition in Nottingham
of letting off a small amount of
explosives as a lecture demonstration
and fashion Floyd is an endothermic
compound so we should have an evolution
of energy with explosives sitting on the
plate of aluminium and under the
aluminium is a coin and when the
explosive goes off the pressure of the
explosion pressing down on the coin
makes an impression like almost like a
mold of the shape of the coin and this
has been done for more than 50 years in
Nottingham using all sorts of different
coins so with a new British pound coin
which has 12 sides it's in the real
opportunity to try it with a new pound
coin but there's a catch you can see
it's made of two pieces a brass colored
ring and the silver centre the coins
we've been used until now in this
experiment have always been solid coins
made of the same material all the way
across when you're handling explosives
in the UK you need a special license and
therefore a former colleague mr. Jim
gamble came in because he has one of
these licenses the experiment itself is
really quite interesting it's the
reaction of white phosphorus which is
the very reactive form of phosphorus
with potassium chlorate it is
fantastically dangerous to mix white
phosphorus with potassium chlorate but
Jim has a special method of doing it
which is safe but even with Tim's method
once the chemicals are mixed quite often
they explode spontaneously
but otherwise you need something warm to
set it off
people say you can set it off with the
warmth of your finger if you did that
you would no longer have a finger so Jim
uses a long metal rod which is heated at
one end and you can see by the length of
this rod I have some respect for that
mixture so what happens is that when you
touch the material with the warm rod it
reacts enormous ly quickly almost in the
millionth of a second so even with our
high-speed camera you don't see the
stages of the reaction one minute there
the next second it's gone when you're in
the room there's a really loud bang it
can be quite frightening when I listen
to it I put my fingers in both ears so
what happens with explosives like this
one which is called a better mating
explosive it goes off very fast the air
that is surrounding everything doesn't
have time to move out of the way
normally at this point as the shock wave
is going downwards the aluminium plate
is pressed onto the coin and it makes
the impression now in this case it was
decided to put the pound coin on a
washer this is a metal ring with a hole
in the middle so the explosion happened
the metal plate was pressed down but now
because the outside of the pound coin
was supported by the washer and the
center wasn't the center of the coin was
blown right out as he watched the
slow-motion
you can see the two bits flying apart I
believe that this is a really good
demonstration of the power of the
explosion the crane yes right she's on
the metal similar it does more central
um we've got another impression of the
coin and over this time again we've
dished it see that's pressed against the
brick it was standing on it was a nice
impression of the brick because it's
rumored and I've heard from quite strong
authorities that if you try and hit the
center of the pound coin with a hammer
you can't do it but here it's flown
right out it also demonstrates the
fantastically good mentality of the coin
because the center comes out without any
damage at all
the unfortunate thing is you're not
allowed to damage coins we were trying
to get a nice 12 sided impression on the
piece of metal so I hope we'll be
forgiven in future when we do this
demonstration we won't use pound coins I
should stress that these experiments
were done with my pound coins so we
hadn't spent any university money on
trying to demonstration and the gas just
touching it is enough to start the fire
think of that just the cold gas setting
things on fire